okay alrighty
starting in five four three
two
thank you for your kind introductions
the title of my presentation
is ips cells derived and patient derived
intestinal organized for
gastrointestinal research
for today's agenda i will first give a
brief overview of organoids
what they are and their advantages and
their limitations
then i will introduce you to our ips
derived covalent organoid systems and
how to differentiate from ips cells
to colon organoids i will then discuss
the applications that can be used with
these
coding organoids lastly i will go over
our patient-derived intestinal organoid
bowel veins
so what are organoids organoids are
self-organizing three-dimensional
structures derived from either pure
potent stem cells or from primary
tissues
with the ability to recapitulate some of
the spatial architecture and individual
functions of organs
in recent years 3d organoids have
emerged as an important tool for disease
modeling
over the last several years the number
of scientific applications utilized
organized has grown exponentially
organoids are
different from spheroids cultures in
that the spheroids are 3d cultures
derived from established monolayer cell
lines and thus may lack the complex
cellular heterogeneity
and architecture of the tissue of
origins
there are advantages of using organoids
because they are derived from patient
tissues and are from stem cells they
contain mixture of cell types and
thus mimic the complex in vivo cellular
heterogeneity
of the primary organs they can also be
frozen and expanded over multiple
passages
biobank may be created uh which retains
structure and function of care and
characteristic of primary t-shirt of
origin finally they can
be genetically manipulated using crispr
technology
and there are also limitations of using
organoids
first is the isolation and culture of
organoids from primary tissues may
require experience and training
while protocol to differentiate ips
cells
to organoids are lengthy and complex
they are also expensive they also
require expensive factors such as or
spawning
aspartame 3a and noggin protein to
culture them
these proteins may require lots of large
clarification to reduce
the variability between lots organoid
may be also of
variable shapes and size thus making it
difficult to implement them
in high throughput as screening assay
typically organoids are derived from
either embryonic or induced pure protein
stem cells
or adult some stem cells resected or
biopsy from organs
both types have the unique capacity to
self-renew and differentiate
which are the defining features of stem
cells
the left schematic shows the generation
of a adult stem cell derived also known
as patient-derived organoids from
primary tissue biopsies
tissues are dissociated into single cell
suspension and then embedded in an
extracellular matrix such as
matrigel and grown in the presence of
specific growth factors to direct cell
differentiation
these specific growth factors uh vary
depending on the tissues being cultured
the right schematics depicts the
generation of acrylic protein stem cells
or ips derived stem cell derived
organoids from 2d stem cells culture
that mature into spheroids
these spheroids may be embedded in an
extracellular matrix
and grown in the presence of specific
growth factors to
the tissue of interest
to circumvent some of these limitations
mentioned earlier
a milipro sigma has developed our human
coded organoid systems
this system includes kits to allow
researchers
to take their human ips cells and
through a step-wide process to
differentiate
purepulmonary stem cells due to
defending definitive
endoderm to hang that endoderm and
eventually into coated organoids
the entire process takes around 48 days
the media kits are chemically defined
they do not contain serum and are
subject to extrinsic
quality control
we show that the resulting
how differentiated media kits have been
validated on two different ips lines
one from human foreskin fibroblast and
the other from pbmc to derive human ips
cells
we showed that the resulting organoids
expressed appropriate markers indica
indicative of multiple cell types found
in the codon including goblet cells
enterocyte panda cells and
enteroendocrine cells
choline organoids are can be preserved
propagated and expanded over multiple
passages for research
for researchers who may not want to go
through the lengthy differentiation
process
we also offer crowd preserved human ips
cells derived
coding organized and expansion media the
coated organoids can be used for a
variety of applications including
gi absorption and toxicity screens of
oral drugs
metabolism and infectious disease
modeling
step one is to start with a high quality
human ips cells grown in a few to free
conditions
if your ips cells are not already in
feeder-free conditions we recommend that
you transition
transition them to free culture for
several passages before starting
ipsl should express high level of pure
potent markers such as the r4
12-1.60 and the sc-4
make sure your ips cells are
undifferentiated by having compact
colonies with distinct borders and
well-defined edges as shown
differentiated cells must be cleaned up
on the dissecting microscope before
initiation of differentiation once your
ips cells have been determined to be of
high quality
dissociate ips cells to single cells
using acumen
and culture overnight in the presence of
rock inhibitors
the next day cell should be around about
85
to 90 percent confluence to start
definitive endoderm differentiation by
adding
definitive endoderm induction media from
day one to day three it's a three-day
induction process
change media every 24 hours on day four
of the on day four one of the well is
sacrificed for co-staining with cxcr4
and stock 17
to test for the differentiation
efficiency for
definitive endoderm by flow cytometry
double positive for cxcl4 plastoc-17
must be greater than 90 percent before
proceeding to the hindgut different
kind gut endoderm differentiation
to analyze by flow for the percent
purity of your definitive endoderm
start with the unseen samples and create
a quadrant gate
with the unstained sample then use this
gate to determine the presence of cd x4
alone and stock 17 alone
and most importantly the cxc of four
plus stock 17 double positive
populations
as you can see the percentage of purity
the percent purity of cxcl4
stock 17 population is greater than 90
if for some reason the percent um double
positive is below 90 percent
and the positive then the possible
causes are that you're starting ips
cells are not of high quality
we recommend um to check for pure
potency for the r4 the trial 160
and the fc-4 markers and also make sure
that your ips cells are pure and not
differentiated before initiate
the the differentiations and also your
ips cells on day one is either too
sparse or too confluent
make sure that your ips cells are
completely single cells are detached
before counting
clumps can affect accuracy in cell
counting
on day four to day seven begin handgun
endotherm differentiation by adding
heingan and the term induction media to
the culture every 24 hours
on day eight sacrifice one well for
flow cytometry for the expression of the
hindgut
endoderm marker cdx2 before proceeding
percent cdx2 positive must be greater
than 60
before proceeding to the next step the
image on the lower left shows the
appearance of spheroids on day six of
differentiation
spheroids are more abundant on day seven
and eight the dot plant on the right is
an example of our flow analysis
for the expression of cdx2 on day 8 of
differentiation
the higher the percentage of cdx 2 the
better
if the percentage of cdx 2 is below 60
the possible causes are again your ips
cells are not of high quality
and that your ips cells on day one is
either too small
or too confluent
on day 8 transition
to 3d growth human coordinate organo
expansion media
change media every other day until day
20.
on day 20 dissociate into single cells
and embed in growth factors
reduce major dome preferably 25
microliter
long size we recommend doing a one to
five fifty and
one to one hundred dilution first to
determine the optimal number of cells to
embed
aim for approximately ninety percent of
frequency in
growth factor major gel domes the image
on the lower left show the appearance of
high intestinals on day 12 of
differentiation
more hydrospheres are present on day 20.
an example of single cells from day 20
is
is shown
the cells are the culture of single
cells from day 20
into 25 microliter growth factor
nitrogen dome in a 24 well plate
the appearance of the coal and organoid
with budding are observed on day 12 in
growth factory-reduced major gel zone as
shown
our ips derived coated organoids can be
passage over a long period of time
the image on the left is the first 12
days
in growth factor reduced matrix of domes
designated as patches zero note that the
developing organelles are not material
yet they do not have the budding
they do not have much butting day 42 is
day 10 of passes one
organoids are bigger and have more
multiple budding and the
and the morphology is more complex
on day 52
is um passage day 52 is day 10 of
passage 2 and organoids have complex
structure with budding
at this stage these organoids are
considered to be mature
day 428 that day 428 is day 9 of passage
37
and this serve as an import example of
uh is served as an example that our ips
derived coding organoids can be passed
many times the organoids do have
the complex 3d structure with buttings
we recommend passes every 10 to 12 days
using organoid dissociation reagents
we do not recommend exceed 12 days
before passaging
on the first two days of every passage
rough inhibitor is added to enhance
viability
thereafter rock eye is not necessary
organoids can be crowd preserved in
codon expansion media
plus 10 dmso or organized freeze media
it is important to monitor your
organized culture of daily
as you can see the organ looks
translucent on day 10
and day 12. from day 14 onward organoid
looks less translucent
and the center looks very dark and dense
thus we have determined that the optimal
passage time is 12
10 to 12 days preferably 10 days
if you go past 14 days the organized
starts to look dark
and just start to form the aquatic ball
that starts to disintegrate at the edges
as seen by the red arrows
for those that do not prefer to go
through the differentiation protocol
we also offer crowd-preserved human ips
derived coal and organized and expansion
media
our crop reserve 3d human coated
organisms contain
2 400 about 2 400 organelles provide or
sufficient for 12 times 25 microliter
dome
in a 24 well plate each dome has about
60 to 70 percent organ or occupancy
two days after thought as seen on the
image to the left
by day seven there are about 90 percent
organ occupancy in each dome
we recommend passaging at a conservative
once you do it ratio
until uh become more familiar with
culturing organoids
uh if by day 10 you see you don't see 90
occupancy you can still salvage
packaging at
a more conservative one to two ratio
here are the examples and
recommendations
for 70 to 90 occupancy
pass it at about one to three until
become familiar with culturing organoids
from forty to seventy percent occupancy
passage as one to two
for thirty percent and below receive
back into the same number of domes
we characterize our ips derived colony
organoids with these markers on the list
by
hormone immunofluorescence stainings the
four that are highlighted in red are the
conan specific markers
they are carbonic anhydrous 2 carbon
anhydrous 4
museum 5b and fat b2 and they are
all expressed in our ips derived chronic
organoids in addition to the rest on the
list
here are the icc data of the staining
they are positive for the corner
specific marker against
ca 2 ca4 and museum 5b
the posterior marker c the x2 mark
cdx2 is expressed along with the
lrg5 which is the stem cell marker
expressed at the base of the crypts
also positive are the epx b2 the sky-1
museum ii e-cadherins and epithelial
marker and the pthat
which is an enteroendocrine cell marker
to confirm the expression of gata4 and
stat b2 expression of our ips derived
coded organoids
we stained alongside a patient-derived
colon organoid line and found that both
express set b2
and gala4 both markers are expressed in
the nucleus and they are
and they overlap with that e as shown
we found that the gala for mrna is
expressed in the stomach duodenum
small of the small intestine and the
codon form and colon from bulk
sequencing data
on protein atlas.org as shown here
we get often asked whether
our ips cell derived coding organoids
expressed by maintain
which is a mexican cell marker we tested
for the expression of by maintained by
flow cytometry using our ips cell
and mcs7 as a negative control and
mdamb2 231 as a positive control
results show that the our ips derived
coronal organoids are negative for by
vimenting we also recently sequenced our
ips derived code and organized and
patient derived coronary organelle line
along with our ips cells by rna-seq
here is a bi-clustering heat map that
showed the expressing profiles of the
top
30 differentially expressed genes in all
three samples
both ips derived code and organoids and
the patient-derived chronic organoids
express patterns that are very similar
to each other but are very different
from the ips
cells besides the top 30 differentially
expressed genes
both ips derived coded organoids and
patient-derived coronary organelles
share similar expression
trends for some coding genes are shown
in this graph
next i want to shift our attention to
the cytotoxicity drug screen application
data generated by colleagues by our
colleagues in germany
for the toxic toxicity screen
seven compounds with well-known effects
along with three merc serrano compounds
were tested
screenings was performed on four days
all organoids four replicas were
performed with a concentration ranging
from 10 nanomolar
to 30 micromolar dmso was used at the
vehicle
metformin which is a drug used to treat
type 2 diabetes which
which is known to be well tolerated was
used as a control as well
cell viability essay was cell
viability was assay after 72 hours of
treatment
the protocol is fairly simple and it's
also detailed on our
sigma website basically harvest the dome
and pass it according to protocol
the 10 microliter major gel dome into a
96 wall plate in 100 microliter
expansion media plus the rock inhibitors
incubate at 37 degree uh incubator
uh in in the presence of five percent
called co2
for three days on day four replaced with
media plus compounds
that measure cell viability at 72 hours
later
these are the those response
cytotoxicity results of different drugs
on our ips derived conan organoids
flabo pyridol was the first cdk
inhibitor in human clinical trials it is
known to induce program cell death
its toxic effect on our ips throughout
chronic organoids is consistent with
expectation
gibsonif and low paramine also exhibit
toxic effect as expected
metformin what is known
to be well tolerated do not
we do not observe any apparent
cytotoxicity even at 750 microderm
concentrations this is consistent with
expectations
an example of drugs which has no
apparent cytotoxicity
effect on cholera organoids are
paracetamol
training tylenol and ketoprofen
a non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drug
that is used to treat arthritis
and a loss saturn the training is
electronics
which is used to treat diarrhea and
severe about
irritable bowel syndrome
of the drugs tested seven of nine
confirmed with expectations
ongoing qualifications of additional gi
tox compound is required to determine
predicted value of gi top
models for high throughput screens
it is important to have consistent
welterweight reproducibility
in this experiment we dissociate coated
organoids into single cells and plated
them at 25 000 cells per dome
five days after seeding we see that each
well contains
domes with similar number of uh viable
cells
single cell dissociate codon organoid
will reassemble
into 3d organoids as shown into the in
the image on the right
there is size variability within wells
but well to wear consistency
observed on different plating density
are possible
thus providing flexibility in when to
initiate experimental
treatment we also performed forskolin
induced running essay on our ips drive
coronary organelles and found
that the cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator short for short c
t f c f t r genes
is functional the ips derived coding
organoids
in the left image do not swell in the
absence of forskolin
when 10 microliter when 10 microliter
forskolin is added to the culture
swelling is observed starting at 3.5
hours
and onward a 36 hour time lapse video
can be found on our website
we now offer a com we now offer a
comprehensive biobank of highly
characterized tissue derived human uh
gastrointestinal organoids from
normal and disease patients which have
been developed by researcher at the
university of michigan center for
gastrointestinal research
there will be a total of 58 pdo derived
from
the stomach the duodenum and ilium of
the small intestines
potent and the rectal samples 17 of
which has recently launched and rna data
for each is available
normal and disease derived from codon
adenoma
ulcerative colitis and crohn's disease
are also
on the list these pdo's are of low
passage
and they are highly viable upon stars
all are cultured in the optimized 3d
grow lwr
and conditioned media here are a few
example images
of of our pdos
five are from normal tissues and the one
on the lower right hand corner is from
colorectal adenoma
tissues
here is the detailed list from
our web page showing the age sex organ
and whether the pdos are from normal or
diseased
tissues the first 17 in blue are
recently launched
here is the characterization data by icc
of a patient-derived coding organoid
is they are part it is positive for
coding specific marker the ca2ca4 and
museum 5b
the posterior hindgut cdx2 marker is
also expressed along with the lrg5 which
is the stem cell marker expressed at the
base of the crypt
it is also positive for epx b2 the scale
1
mu2 museum 2 e-cadherin which is an
epithelial marker
and a tph-1 which is an
enteral endocrine cell marker
now i would like to briefly discuss
about fall corporate 2 and its effect on
the gut
and troll site recent publication have
shown
that the intestinal the intestine may be
may present another viral target organ
study has reviewed that sarcoid 2
receptor angiotensin converting enzyme
to
h2 for short is highly expressed in the
small intestines
let's first look at the general
structure of sarcoma virus
speaker 1a depicts the structure of salt
carbohydrate
with the main cytoglycoprotein of the
four essential glycoprotein
it is the s or the spike glycoproteins
that binds to the host cells
h2 receptor that allows for virus entry
triple speed defect shows a linear map
of a spike glycoprotein
its n-terminus s1 unit contains the
receptor binding domain
which is required for binding to the
host h2 receptor
the c-terminus s-tune unit contain the
functional elements required for fusion
it is also contained it also contains a
transmembrane domain for membrane
anchoring and the cytoplasmic domain
i tell for appropriate intracellular
trafficking
there are two routes of entry a virus
entry into the host cells
one is the receptor-mediated endocytosis
initiated by the binding of the viral
spike glycoprotein
to the ace receptor of the whole cell
the virus then end up in the endoscope
zone where the low ph
level activates capacitance l
capacitance then activate the viral
spike
glycoprotein and facilitate viral
membrane fusion
resulting in the release of its
genomic material which is the single
strand rna
out of the endosome and into the
cytoplasm alternatively
the spike glycoprotein then be can be
cleaved by surface protease on the cell
surface called the tempress 2
and this can lead to the direct fusion
of the viral and plasma membrane
resulting in the releasing of the viral
single strand rna into the cycloplasm
patient-derived duodenum organoid
expresses both ace2 and temperous
markers
thus it may be suitable for use as
experimental model for the study of
coronavirus infection and its biology
beside our human intestinal organoid
system we also offer general organoids
qualifying
reagents such as our lwr and media
supplement for culturing
pdos and also our spawning one condition
media supplement
we also offer organoid dissociation
reagent and organoid freeze media
we also have all one-in-one expressions
293 t-cells
available for making conditioned media
we recently launched
[Music]
our lung human lung organoid system as
shown here
this system consists of all the
necessary differentiating media for
generating material lung blood organoid
ips derived anterior foregut endoderm is
also available for further
differentiation to mature blood
organoids
in summary human coded organoids can be
generated from ips cells using a
stepwise
differentiation protocol along with
alchemically
defined and serum free media kit ips
cells
ipsl's derived coding organoid can be
preserved
propagated and expanded in long-term
culture
they also express appropriate markers
indicative of
multiple cell types found in the colon
those can um
they can be single cells dissociated to
control for consistency
in organoid uh number from well to
wealth for high throughput um
screening they also show similar trends
to that of patient derived coded
organoid by rna-seq
they also can be used in cytotoxicity
drug screenings
and also their cystic fibrosis may trim
membrane
transmembrane conduction regulator gene
is functional
also 58 of 58 total gastrointestinal
organoids are available
from normal to disease tissue with low
passages
with low passage number our patient
derived duodenum organ
expressed expresses express two sarcoid
ii
cellular entrance marker h2 and
temperature ii
i would like to ignore lastly i would
like to acknowledge my colleague
on the list for making the 3d organ
product possible
i also would like to recognize our
colleague in germany for the
phytotoxicity data
lastly i would like to recognize the
team at the university of michigan
center for gastrointestinal research
for making the pdo about bank possible
thank you for your attention
and i'm looking forward to your question
okay awesome job well we're all set
pretty much from here too fast
no i thought it was great i thought you
uh communicated clearly and smoothly
thanks do you know how long it takes
about 28 to 30 minutes i guess
yeah it looks like about 28 minutes so
good timing
okay great awesome well pretty much from
here i'll just do some quick editing on
the front
back ends and get your presentation
ready for the event next week
uh-huh um is that possible that we can
look at the
um the recording before the presentation
definitely i'll send you a review link
once it's ready
okay all righty and then this is all for
today basically right
uh yes if any questions come up
definitely feel free to ask but if not
i'll send the preview link once it's
ready
okay and one last question for the
actual recording
i think the email mentioned that i need
to log in i think it started 10 30 and i
need to log in at 10 o'clock right
oh that that is right yes so um marianne
just
let me know that you will be doing live
q a
so yes 30 minutes prior just to
do some prep and talk with your
moderator and then
presentation 10 30. okay
all righty okay that's great thank you
so much tyler for your help
thank you have a good rest of your day
we'll talk to you soon ok you as well
thank you bye
bye